[Music]
we are seeing a great deal of emphasis
on using alcohol-based hand sanitizers
they are meant to keep us safe from the
threat of the novel coronavirus disease
but is that the only way do we really
need to buy hand sanitizers for use at
home once soap and water suffice this
video will give you a quick answer with
a brief explanation hand-washing with
soap and water is ideal because it
reduces all types of germs on our hands
when it comes to certain germs and
chemicals hand sanitizers are just not
as effective as soap and water but then
what to fear in a situation where
there's no soap and no water
definitely a hand sanitizer will help us
avoid getting sick and spreading germs
to others when we use hand sanitizers we
need to make sure that an ample amount
is used and it shouldn't be wiped off
before it is dry yes
the amount used matters too little will
not keep you safe so make sure to use
the recommended amounts stated on the
label a couple of advantages of hand
sanitizers are that they take much less
time to do the job and they are gentler
on our hands and not as abrasive as
soaps but we also need to keep in mind
that hand sanitizers do not work well
when our hands are visibly soiled or
greasy at such times it's best to use
soap and water
so long story short both work but when
you have a choice always pick soap and
water but an important question we need
to ask ourselves about this is how long
should we wash our hands for the widely
stated duration is 20 seconds but is 20
seconds enough it's a minimum the main
objective is to have clean hands it
could easily take longer than 20 seconds
to cover each and every area of our
hands which are commonly missed parts
you ask thumbs fingertips areas between
the fingers are often missed and don't
forget the back of your hands back of
your hands are frequently neglected
washing is not just about long enough
but also well enough many of our friends
may be unaware of this educate them
openness to share this video with them
and they will know better stay safe and
help everyone stay safe here's a
question for you
how does something as simple as a soap
work in eliminating the corona virus
that will be the topic of the next
lesson
[Music]